[Music]
[Applause]
hello girls
i have snacks for you come here
the walrus section of the zoo is
australian themed but you do not need an
australian accent to go in we have a lot
of playgrounds for the kids to play on
there's water park we have wallabies and
koalas i would say my favorite is
wallabies hello love book you don't come
over for a peanut
good job they really like to use their
hands they're super inquisitive and
friendly
great job lady
she's like bye
[Music]
also when wallaru we have two doll
koalas
it is relatively rare to have koalas in
zoos in the united states i came to see
heathcliff
we have heathcliff who is the male koala
he is pretty laid back super chill you
want some of this buddy
like just put it in there we'll see what
happens
and then we have seduna who is the
female she's a little spunkier do you
know yoga poses today she is she's been
doing some silly stuff
oh my gosh we brought you snacks
that's like me in front of a bowl of ice
cream oh yes
we have not seen a ton of interest
between heathcliff and duna as far as
reading goes she seemed to be very
protective of her pouch today so i'm not
sure really okay what's going on seduna
wears the pants in that relationship
they have two different bedrooms she is
welcome to go to his room but heathcliff
goes to her room and she'll usually move
him out what's going on she's just kind
of hanging out we could try to do a
pouch check now we do a pouch check
every 30 days just to make sure that
there's not a joey and the pouch looks
okay
i mean she's looking pretty relaxed so i
think if we want to give it a shot i
think i could probably stick my finger
in there now but give it a shot
no
i don't think so
no she doesn't want me touching it
lately when we kind of touched near that
area she's a little bit sensitive she'll
draw back where normally she would be
completely fine with it we might wait
until um until monday to do this okay
just so that she's not stressed out
she's due for her two-year checkup my
fingers are crossed i really really
really hope we have a joey you know it
just doesn't seem like we do from
looking at her from the outside but it's
very possible it is at an angle that
it's tucked to the side and we just
don't know
knowing if a koala is pregnant can be
difficult because when they're born
they're only 30 days old and they're
super tiny
and they crawl into the pouch and attach
to one of the teens when they're that
small and inside kind of a cushy pouch
you can't tell
we'll just wait to see what we see in
the pouch on monday
all right
koalas aren't endangered however it's
always good to be on top of genetics so
we'd like to keep that number growing
but the big picture is not about the
zoo's family it's about the potential
of that species living on for
generations to come
bye seduna
you being a good girl
i'm really excited
welcome to zoo tampa my name is alex now
to the right hand side we're gonna see
the aldabra tortoises when fully grown
they can reach weights of up to and
around 500 pounds on average
all right we need a length and a width
on this shell here okay
bruce is an aldabra tortoise which comes
from the aldabra toll off the east coast
of africa 41 and three fourths they are
the second largest tortoise species in
the world
bruce is actually 57 years old but
currently there's one that's about 187
that's living on an island in the
atlantic so
he could potentially live another
hundred years or more
you gotta get that sweet spot
you can you can feel the weight
difference yeah he's yeah i've noticed
that over the last few weeks too
what's concerning about bruce this year
is we've started to notice weight loss
as well as bruce isn't moving around as
much
every winter he does tend to lose a
little weight and he does seem to go
into shutdown mode but this year we kind
of saw a little bit more than we're used
to
so we're just concerned that more is
going on we want to make sure we bring
him back to full health so he can live
with us for a very long time
okay
hello hey nico here we have mr bruce yep
he's been eating pretty well for us but
it's not it's not where we want it not
where it's been in the past yeah
bruce is amazing he is really cool some
of them have different personalities
some of them are more shy but bruce is a
really nice guy i just want to make sure
that he is okay
i'm hoping that his heart is okay
so
the plan is to get an electrocardiogram
on him
if we can have some food that we can
offer him while we're doing this that
will be great all right all right
i got him these flowers
here you go buddy
i won't even give my wife flowers
[Laughter]
this instrument is an electrocardiogram
and it gives you more information about
the electrical activity of the heart it
will probably give us a really good idea
of what his heart might be doing
so hard working under 300 pound tortoise
this year we're also seeing him have a
more difficult time supporting his body
we're worried that we're on a kind of a
slope downhill
and i'm not getting the um the reading
that i want
i think the machine is having trouble
because his heart rate is so low
he's officially a rock
that's it that's one we got a good we
get it we got a good one in here okay
i think it's a challenge for for any
veterinarian that deals with these kind
of species because
it's not a dog it's not a cat it's not
there's not all this research out there
that we can understand
well let's just try it mr ow i would
love to have ao
we're gonna go do al
we wanna get a good baseline of what a
healthy tortoise would have for a heart
rate and we can then compare that to
bruises to indicate if there's problems
i think that's probably right then ryan
yeah because i'm getting
about 12 beats per minute
so
we're getting a more normal beating on
mr owl here
bruce
was a lot slower
there might be something going on
what i want to make sure is that you
guys keep feeding him feeding him
fitting and rapport of any kind of
little change hopefully it's not
something major with his heart because
that's something that we'll have a
really difficult time rectifying and
i don't want to say bye to bruce anytime
soon
[Music]
who wouldn't love that face look how
cute he is
mintari is a silhouette babarussa
babarusa literally translates to pig
deer in indonesian
i
love mintari i really do with all my
heart
he could do this all day long
i've raised mantari since he was a baby
i was about this
this big um he's coming up to be about
two years old now and reaching sexual
maturity so that means we're gonna need
to start finding him a girlfriend and
increase the population of babarus's
around the world the female that mantari
is getting paired with is actually at
another facility so sometime soon we're
gonna actually have to say goodbye to
him why are you fascinated with my ring
today
but we do have two weeks left with
antare where i'll get to spoil him
before he actually gets transferred and
hopefully start a new family of his own
it's definitely gonna be bittersweet to
see him leave i don't have any food for
you right now
before he goes he is scheduled for a
full exam at the vet's office which
includes trimming his tusks back in the
wild there's actually been cases shown
where the male babarus's tusks grow back
into their skull
and kill them
okay
almost ready little man
in order to get mintard hold still for
the test trim we're gonna have to give
him a sedation
all right sir
today we are gonna be doing a mock
session uh of a hip inject with mintari
you wanna get some scratches
okay do you want to try scratching him
with that brush
ventari loves the rub down oh what is
that sir there we go
oh good job mister
we walked through this several times in
hopes that when he does get the regular
injection he shouldn't react at all all
right you ready for a stick
he's ready
sticking
good job
he has a slight reaction basically just
a little bit of a butt twitch but
besides that he's reacting perfectly to
it all done
he said no we're done he wants us to
keep going
and the next session he'll actually get
the real deal he'll get an actual needle
piece of cake or grape i'm very
confident that he's gonna do very well
what song would a stingray like
under the sea
ooh maybe
watch sir like ac dc fans
one of the joys of my job is i get to
work with aquatic species and i love
working with stingrays and it's always
really exciting to me to be able to work
hands-on with these species that i know
live in our backyard out in the state of
florida
all right
you just got snubbed i did
so kitty on the two girls have you seen
any more distention or anything
different okay cause last time we
ultrasounded them we didn't see any
fetuses right no
we do have a male but because he likes
to keep breeding with our females
we had to remove them and put him in our
quarantined area it gives the females a
little bit of a break because after
doing pregnancy after pregnancy there's
a lot of stress on their body we don't
actually want these animals to be
pregnant at this point
how can you tell which one's which
darker ones tracy lighter one is mine
yeah
come on
the staff has been working very hard on
getting the stingrays to actually
station voluntarily for some ultrasound
images
come on
yay
target training is basically asking the
animal to come up
good girl when we first started doing
this stingray training with them they
actually
got it right on the spot okay here we go
yeah no babies
babies no babies
come on martha
come on don't don't follow your sister
come here
good girl there you go
the stickers are just basically goof
balls they're
honestly they remind me of a golden
retriever they have so much personality
i know
they know when to purposely splash a gas
to get their attention they will slap
the wall sometimes i
i love them
that's my hand
all right
i didn't see babies on any of them
that's a good thing though
we're cool all right cool thank you
so no stingray pups at this time that's
okay it's what we were hoping to find
and for now we're to actually keep the
lady stingrays and the male stingray
stewart separated for a couple of weeks
give them a rest from breeding until we
introduce him back into the main pool
[Music]
hi good morning
all right you ready to get this girl
ready to go all right so this morning we
are going to sedate our female koala
we're going to pounce check her we're
going to pull some blood and do some hip
and shoulder checks for dysplasia she
can be a little yeah cranky so we'll
give her a little something one of the
things that mislead people most about
koalas is that yeah they're cute they're
adorable
but they can be ornery all right sweet
girl ready
[Music]
all right we're gonna give her a little
sedation
i wonder nice and calm for this
procedure got her yes all right she's
doing the superman
would you call animal duty in the clinic
please thank you ma'am
you comfy yep we are good
all right michelle we got a flying koala
we want to um get a set of radiographs
we're looking at her shoulders and we
want to really document her as she's
growing because she's still a pretty
young girl before we do anything check
the pouch just just to double check yeah
yeah yeah
we want to just confirm there's not a
joey before we continue on
it's dirty in there instead it's really
yeah it's kind of
gunky in there but
oh it's very gunky it's very dirty this
is weird
it looks a little bit
moist yeah it is that's
strange that's odd
that's a little
unusual
when there's not supposed to be a joey
in the pouch have you actually seen them
breathe yet i've been courting a little
bit but i'm here and there yeah but not
yeah i didn't think so either i feel i
wait something is that yup yup look at
that
oh it's very gunky it's very dirty wow
weird yeah that's not
are doing a workup on our female koala
seduna
feel uh
wait something
i'm putting my hand in seduna's pouch
and it's much deeper than it has been in
the past is that yeah
that's why there's so much in there
that's amazing
oh my god
this is so exciting
i'm so happy about this because i didn't
expect for there to be a joey i was
preparing for something to be wrong
we found a baby koala
to everyone's surprise
should we put the gunk back
it turns out that brown material that we
found in our pouch was actually um
joey poo
yeah this joey is this big yeah between
here and here
this little joey
i would guess is probably a little less
than 60 days old three more months maybe
we'll start to see a nose kind of pop
out
heathcliff did it
who to guess good job
heathcliff is a little bit of a a
sluggish boy
so no one's seen any breeding so for
them to pull it off
has surprised us
okay
let's wake her up yep we don't need to
do this
oh my god
we're calling off the exam we're
reversing her and we'll take her back to
her house
this is very exciting well you know we
waiting we don't mind pleasant surprises
this is the first koala joey this
institution's ever had all right a
little reversal there
sometimes you never know these animals
are pregnant until you actually get your
hands on them and getting your hands on
them a lot of times it involves
anesthesia
they're just going to be a little sleepy
and then they're going to wake up
together
good morning sunshine you
back hey
there you go
this is what we've been hoping for for a
while but we really didn't have any
strong indications that
they even liked each other to be honest
with you
hey doing sweetheart
there you go
[Music]
keith looks like what is happening
oh are you serious they're kissing
it's
super rewarding to have a pregnancy but
beyond growing our zoo family it's gonna
have a bigger global impact in the
future
saduna you had us all fooled acting like
you didn't like him
[Music]
[Music]
urban style animal style can somebody
give us a hand lifting a tortoise
it's been about two weeks since we've
tested our aldabra tortoise bruce um he
hasn't really recovered from his winter
fog yet he hasn't been eating as much as
we prefer and he's been kind of
lethargic
today we're gonna do a weigh-in for
bruce last time we weighed him he was
just under 290 so we're hoping that he's
at least held that way if not gain some
weight
all right one two three
there you go
watch your step
he's always been kind of a slower to
move tortoise you know he's more
reluctant to get up and move around
but uh he's been just slower than normal
287 let's go about the same
all right we'll go set him down in the
pool
one two three
maintaining weight is a good thing and
that's why we want to check his weight
and make sure that he stays steady
weight wise
all right cool and we can just fill up
all right
so he's at least maintaining well that's
that's a good sign yeah
but he's still weak
i don't have a good grip on what is his
actual problem
any other animal you would have done
surgery you would have opened him up you
would have collected some sample but
he's not strong enough to go under
sedation
the ekgs that we did
haven't got anything to say
his cardiac condition is off or not
his condition could be cardiac his
condition could be cancer his condition
could be
immune system
working so closely with these animals
for a long time um you get to learn
their personalities and you can you can
tell when something's off
so
with bruce we definitely are seeing a
big personality change with him
we're going to continue to do the
research on him um
we have him on antibiotics but
we we're we're concerned about him
[Music]
clinic to asia
he what's your uta over fermentary we
are ready to head over okay we'll see
you when you get here
today we are going to be doing a
sedation on atari so that we can
transport him up to our clinic we're
going to be trimming back his tusks a
little bit pigs are notoriously
difficult um at times to sedate because
they've got a lot of fat on them and you
really want to make sure you get a nice
intramuscular injection
dr lauren is on her way
we love antare he's such a sweet boy
we've been practicing a hip inject
procedure training with mintari for
several months now so today's the big
day hopefully everything goes well let
me use scratches
oh yes it's the best
how's he doing
it's good
the minute jackie and katie scratch him
down i mean he's down for the count all
right you got him yep all right cover
your eyes sir
when i first did the injection ventari
you know he kicks his leg a little bit
kind of like what was that something
stung me and then goes right back into
you just scratched me down
i'm very happy that went like that that
was amazing
he seems really nice and sleepy and a
good safe plane of sedation to move him
up to the clinic so that we can continue
with his exam all right
in route with babarussa let's keep his
head up elevated somewhat
while mantari is under full anesthesia
we're going to give him a complete
physical exam we're going to take some
x-rays we're going to collect some blood
on him
okay we're doing more and i'm going to
trim up his tusks and get him set to go
on to another facility
someone got that right there which is it
did it
good job i think the training definitely
helped
great he seems pretty deep i think we
can try
a little twitch on that leg we'll twitch
okay yeah yeah
[Music]
a little twitch on that leg we'll twitch
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so my graphic mask please
[Music]
let's just go ahead with this real quick
we'll be okay
piggies are zero to 60.
yeah that's all fooled oh yeah he's like
i'm fine
real life i'm just gonna wait
good job guys yay he basically fooled us
we thought he was sedated i just want to
like be able to help them yeah go sleep
it's fine
all right so we've got a dremel
so ladies i don't want you guys to get
shot yeah
[Music]
nice i like power tools
he didn't have a whole lot that i needed
to take off and it only had really a
couple of centimeters that i needed to
remove
check it out jackie
i saw the
tusk fly oh you want to save a piece
yeah she's like that's mine
all right i think we're wrapping up yep
hey
he looks handsome
steering's up on the other end there we
got it
playing for transport y'all's den is
ready to go the staff has made him a
nice comfy hayden you know move around
quite a bit during the recovery process
we want to make sure he doesn't harm
himself
all right i think that's good
so now this is this is good progress you
just got to give them time he's starting
to get all his motor function back
together
yeah you're doing much better
and down again
ventare is looking very handsome with
his new test trim in a few days mantari
is going to go to his new home and get
paired with his new female lady friend
and producing baby mintaris of his own
we'll miss him but we know what's best
for a boy you're doing good
you're doing good
[Music]
hello everyone
how are you guys today
here to do a koala photo experience yep
perfect
we just started a new photo experience
with our male koala heathcliff people
get the chance to pose for a little
photo shoot
ready to say hi to heathcliff
yeah okay let's do this
andrea from the marketing team is the
brains behind the koala encounter she is
obsessed with heathcliff i love them so
much
koalas are my favorite animal here at
the zoo i think they smell divine they
smell like angels look he's walking
did you ever think you would be so close
to a koala
koalas are one of the most expensive
animals to feed at the zoo they have a
very expensive diet they eat a super
toxic plant it's the only thing they eat
eucalyptus we get it shipped in from a
farm a few hours south in florida so it
costs a lot to feed the koalas oh my
gosh did you see that jump i'm freaking
out
we wanted to come up with a way
for people to get close to them and take
a great photo can everyone turn around
look at heathcliff that was a way for us
to help pay for them to be here help pay
for that food yay
[Applause]
what a stud he's such a star
when do you think um the joey's gonna
pop out so i don't know it does seem
like it's pretty big right now
he club has no idea he's going to be a
dad
[Music]
hi good morning do you want some
breakfast
hey stuart time to go see your ladies
you ready
i think we're gonna be good to lift okay
stuart is our male southern stingray
got him in
he's been in quarantine for about four
or five months the reason why we moved
him was so then we didn't get the
females pregnant however he's starting
to get a little bit discoloration on him
today he's getting his checkup which he
was going to get his checkup regardless
but we just kind of made it a little bit
more a priority
[Music]
hey hey good morning katie how's it
going good we're just grooving him
he definitely has some admiral
discoloration
southern stingrays are usually kind of a
tannish to gray color and he looks very
abnormal to me
oh
okay let's go so we're going to put
stewart into an outside pool we're going
to let him soak up some sun
we're going to check on him in a couple
of weeks and hopefully everything's back
to normal
[Music]
so how much did he eat he ate a little
bit of the lettuce he ate some bananas
okay i'm glad he ate
ah bruce bruce how you doing buddy did
you enjoy your breakfast in bed
breakfast with bruce
bruce has basically just slowed down
he's been waking up a little bit more
grumpy so rachel sat inside today and
hand fed him but the problem is he's uh
he's not eating as much as we want them
to
they're very stoic they're very tough
you know you're not gonna
know when there's something wrong with
them if they have some subtle illness or
they're just not feeling right those
things are very very hard to pick up on
so when we do see some things that catch
our eye that brings us to our you know
attention
you know it's probably very significant
dr ray's coming um he'll check him out
okay
we're gonna physically move bruce into
the pool one two three
and then we'll go through soaking him to
make sure he doesn't get dehydrated
all right that's the hard part
[Music]
all right i got three sizes for you
sizes all right
hi buddy
i know we're just gonna sneak this under
your head
tortoises hold their breath for quite a
long time they still have lungs just
like a human does so they can still take
in water and drown so we're gonna use a
pool noodle
so that
if he does feel weak that something else
will keep his head above water
there you go buddy
perfect looking good
nice noodle
it works right it does work no that's
that's perfect
[Music]
see his eyes are rolled up like that
uh-huh
you know it doesn't it doesn't look good
oh bruce bruce
[Music]
see his eyes are rolled up like that
you know it doesn't it doesn't look good
he needs some strength there's no doubt
about it but uh
the way he's just carrying himself is
not as vigorous as we obviously hope to
see with him outside like that
i'm very worried i i'm very worried
about it
one two three
it's nerve-wracking when animals not
doing
good but uh
i i believe we're gonna pull through
this i i have 100 confidence we'll come
through with him
he's gonna get better
okay
um
one step at a time
you're all right buddy
all right taziri be good we'll see you
later
see ya
[Music]
now you got to stay in here
oh to zerry
do you want to come with us
wendy too huh
come on all right come on everybody come
on let's go
let's go check on mintari
i'm like so proud of him he did so well
for the procedure
he
just had his tusks trimmed a couple days
ago we were worried that they were gonna
be penetrating his
nose we caught it just in time though
and just trimmed him up a little bit
he's actually looking really good antari
come on i want to see your tusks
yay
good job look out look how awesome he
looks now
his uh new girlfriend will be
really impressed with him now
because he's so handsome
any girl is going to be lucky to have
him as a as a boyfriend
since he's gonna be leaving soon i
definitely
i'm gonna cry i'm gonna miss him
i'm excited for him to be leaving
because he's going to be with another
babaroosa
but
when they
walk into that crate and you lock it and
you know it's that last time
it's definitely uh
sad
it's a great pig
it's always bittersweet when they go oh
careful bud he's definitely full of
personality yeah
we're gonna miss you big guy
but we know you'll be happy
see you later bye
ladies man yeah
[Music]
the macaw flyover is really one of our
signature encounters that we do here at
zoo tampa you're very fluffed i think
it's just the idea that the birds are
out free and that they can go wherever
they want and people are pretty blown
away that they don't just leave the zoo
and that they stick around and hang
around with us
don't be sassy with each other rude
they will fly out and they'll go to one
perch and then they wait for a queue and
they have another trainer waiting at the
next perch then they fly at head level
so they zip right by people as they're
walking along looking at animals and
their habitats
magoo
are you ready
the grand finale of our flyover is that
all of the birds do a big beautiful
flight around the outside of our manatee
fountain from five
four
three
two
one
[Applause]
[Music]
he's right here
he just blends so well
stuart he's kind of got some
discoloration on him we were hoping that
it's just because he was inside and he's
always been outside however the
discoloration the lines on him really
haven't
gone away so
today we'll be pulling bloods on him and
then we'll just do an actual physical uh
external checkup on him
watch she's just gonna come straight up
to the side you got changed for nothing
that's how it always goes he's not
changed then he'd be in the middle i
know that's what he's talking about
which direction is he headed
oh tyson right here
he's really fast compared to the females
he's like not today
he likes suckers
he was savvy to our exam today he was
trying to avoid tyson
come on jason
woo
good job people be so angry
they're like that it ain't me it's not
aquatics if you don't get wet
here you go i still think he looks
pretty yellow yeah
being outside in the sunshine has not
helped
i'm very worried
i want to get to the bottom of this
it's scary
like if your own child gets sick
you start getting super worried
[Music]
i still think he looks pretty yellow
stewart has some very abnormal
coloration i want to get to the bottom
of this i'm slowing down a little bit
we have him in an induction system and
so this is where he's going to
become very sedate and then we'll move
him over to our anesthesia cart where
we'll do our diagnostics all right yep
a little paranoid
we have a pump with a hose going up and
it's just pushing that water over the
gills to make sure that we're able to
keep them out of the water a little bit
longer
he's a little leaner than the other guys
there's his heart all right very good we
try to get some bloods
be the vessel be the vessel be the one
see it right there
okay
all right sweet
let's flip them over let's just check
them out
like a pancake
[Music]
what does that mean if it's like
elevated like this
so we're noticing these kind of like
brown you know squiggly lines throughout
his entire back and i'm able to pick it
off and it kind of looks like slime so
when i have increased mucus or slime on
any type of fish that's got me concerned
because they will do that when they
don't feel well
i'm gonna do a skin
scrape this is a common practice that we
do and all kinds of fish to pick up on
any type of parasites you know see if
there's any cells that we can find i
think we'll see tickle's back here
he definitely has some excessive sliming
on him
we need to look it in a microscope to
see
what we have
i'm going to go back and see if there's
something that we can potentially treat
or maybe we need to take a next step and
pursue a biopsy
we good to put them in we're good
he's so sweet and i don't want anything
to happen to him
buddy
i'm hoping that it's just something
simple cause i love these stingrays so
much i consider them my kiddos so he's
moving his tail
there we go
[Music]
bruce has had
ups and downs his whole life so
we were hoping that this was another one
where
he would bounce back from it
it was just too much too much to
overcome
unfortunately bruce passed away
we were
trying to do
everything we could but
unfortunately that wasn't enough this
time
this was something that he's probably
been developing for years and it was
problems with the heart problems with
the lungs problems with the liver
just like people
sometimes
sometimes we get taken too early
it's always very difficult when you get
to know these animals day in and day out
especially an animal that lives as long
as an aldaba tortoise
but you know when they do pass
sometimes that's actually the most
compassionate thing that can happen
and i definitely think that's the case
for bruce
he was an
amazing ambassador he touched a lot of
lives he
he was a great tortoise even when he
didn't want to cooperate
[Music]
yeah i will miss bruce
we'll all miss bruce
[Music]
look at deera oh my gosh
how many times a day do we say look at
dira one million
oh my gosh you're so cute
hello hi
so seduna's joey has started to emerge
more from the pouch can we see its face
we want to see your baby
oh yes it's moving
the gestation for koalas is only 30 days
before the baby comes out and moves into
the pouch so it's extremely
underdeveloped and then it stays in
there for close to six months before it
starts venturing out we're probably at
the
170-ish day mark based on the
development we've seen um so we should
be seeing more and more of it
uncross your leg no put that leg
straddle that hole
can you like just do this i like this
give me a move
[Music]
you're giving us nothing
seduna is being one stubborn mom today
so we are gonna see if we can maybe just
maybe bribe her with some delicious
eucalyptus branches to show us her joey
all right
want some more food
you hungry
[Music]
is that an eye
[Music]
is that an eye
i see its face look at that little cute
nose
we've just been waiting and waiting
patiently
or impatiently
oh it's so cute
we see a little face peeking out little
eye
it looks bright-eyed and very healthy so
we're very excited it's our first time
getting to see a little joey
looks just like seduna
with a little miniature koala
we're assuming it's maybe that big it
looks like it might have a head like the
size of a squirrel
eventually it'll start riding on mom's
back and they'll start eating the
eucalyptus and and we'll get to see more
and watch it grow up
[Music]
good morning
are you ready for your checkup
today we're gonna go check up on stuart
he's our male southern stingray his
coloration was off he looked yellow he
had a really nasty thick mucus layer on
him and he had lost some weight
stewart's actually already ready
okay perfect we'll bring him up over
here we'll get a weight on him and i'll
just do a quick look on his skin
stewart has been on a couple of weeks
worth of antibiotics so i'm gonna see
how he did okay i'm gonna go behind him
going forward
you got him nope nope he slid underneath
he knows
yeah
oh he saw it
stingrays are really fast swimmers and
um stewart's evading us which is
actually a really good sign i'll try
this one this one's a lot lighter okay
okay
okay well lift up and scoop perfect
all right
his skin is much better he's not as
yellow
now
every stingray will have a little bit of
variation there so what i'm seeing today
is nowhere near what i saw on the day
one we had our first concerns
and all those tracking lesions and slime
layers i don't see anymore yeah that's
awesome
that's awesome
so i mean we definitely want to back up
my impression that he's looking better i
want to get a weight on him
if sewer hasn't gained weight then that
means we haven't fixed the issue
6.5
oh god
he definitely gave weight
so he's gained a whole kick
that's awesome super excited he's gained
a kilogram so a little over two pounds
i think he was immune suppressed and
what happens is that leaves them open to
secondary infections so i think using
antibiotics was a combination for
success i think it looks fantastic
really nice job
i am ecstatic for the good news that
stewart is looking so much better and
he's gaining weight it's a very good day
for all of us
[Music]
in bali
the bali
come on pretty girl
let's come inside
let's get inside get some breakfast
[Music]
look at the enthusiasm
let's go let's go let's go
is it too hot you're gonna hang in the
shade
yeah i see you peeking
[Music]
she's really not moving she i'm talking
to a log
[Music]
hello
good morning gorgeous girl
we brought you a snack for you and your
baby
[Music]
it's so cute now it's like a mini koala
his head is so round and furry it's
perfect it's perfect
the joey's out it's very exciting
we did find out that the little joey is
a male and his name is sydney and it's
adorable
just in love with this baby
i think everyone is oh it's just too
much
it's perfect it's perfect perfect koala
jelly it looks a lot like seduna
let's come back later today okay okay
twist my arm okay
we're really excited about the joey and
it's it's great to grow our family but
in a bigger picture it's fantastic for
conservation
what we've done in our part is producing
one more koala to meet that goal of
genetic diversity
it's incredible it feels really good
i'm proud to be part of the team that
helped make this happen
[Music]
[Music]
you